les deux violents j'y vais parce qu'on
tire des points très bons pour arriver
jusqu'au bout la plage donc les deux
heures langis voip clairement que la loi
ce qui l'aurait bien deux ans
tranquillement elle assure et puis les
faire sans faille derrière mais on ne
peut pas faire autrement n'y a rien
d'autre à faire que chaque fois de virer
avec le vent s'occupe pas tellement du
chenal on verra dès que le vent est dans
une position comme ça où le fr champsaur
et derrière il est sous le vent est
derrière donc le sens à nous tromper je
peux dire que la presse que la ligne
passe encore coupé brasserie lorraine a
presque les pros a gagné elle le voulait
dans sa commune elle voulait le faire le
coq marinois attendait ça avec
impatience
bémol la première attaque aux vicois
c'est toujours important aussi pour les
supporters pour les poussins qui font de
la gueule au romarin et à 7 cette école
de d'ailleurs l'alizé hurle avec eux
georges henri lagier à bouffer ça fait
déjà mais venir convient ils ont vu ça
les adultes aussi des footeux des gamins
ils ont ce but l'archos ils ont vu que
laguiole a gagné monsieur comment on
peut faire son entrée à l'école j'ai
envie d'apprendre ailleurs c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ça qui est important ce
qu'on fait là bas on le fait pour le
politique spectateurs m'ont fait tous
ceux qui nous regardent
c'est une cause qui commence et c'est
une course est animée et pas banal
bayal qui gagne ne gagne jamais par
hasard elle gagne pense que c'est mieux
que d'autres principes et puis parce
qu'elle oscille en vidant vie de faire
la course devant et et c'est très bien
pour l'instant ce que frau les bas
rhinois un brass et lorraine qui a
peut-être encore un bond de plus
peut-être que ufr champions alors que
liban l'ambiance déjà sur la plage je
suppose que les supporters marine loin
vous ce matin vous avez bien vu puisque
vous avez aimé votre maillot rouge
conçu pour accueillir la voile rouge
c'est celle de brasser le reste a réagi
noël
alors effectivement oui on se retrouve
sur la plage du marin du bourg du marin
le maillot rouge alain ce n'est pas pour
supporter brasserie lorraine c'est parce
que laguiole en général lé vainqueur
c'est elle la championne fait donc du
coup ce sont les yoles et on était avec
des supporters qui commentait la course
madame vous dites vous étiez en train de
caler au cadillac arrivée cabillaud cuit
mais oui mes gars déjà dit hier brasse
tout cas vite et mal accueilli les
maghrébins
fabien maghrébins subalpine at elle dit
c'est le mariage ne permet d'assurer des
zones habitées non très bien alors vous
êtes en train de narguer les marginaux
et pourquoi pas chez eux mêmes nous
allons dépasser du championnat on va
justement rejoindre les supporters
marinoise ceux de brasserie lorraine
très rapidement ils ont déjà leurs
groupes de carnaval qui font déjà de la
musique et du tapage pour pouvoir
accueillir leur idole
on y va tout de suite on se retrouve
dans quelques secondes d'accord merci
kelly alors on va faire la fête avec les
supporters donc de brasser lors elle se
rend il est agile veulent encore attirer
l'acheteur dire également alors qu'il
faut pas du tapage et le groupe le
couple de carnaval que vous voyez est
sponsorisée tout ce monde-là départ
brasse kg vélo c'est presque normal que
soit l'âge ou du light un jeudi que la
cause théoriquement à cause gagnée mais
il tente it up bourrasques et leur
démenti un petit peu au félix essaie
toujours de s'échapper de toujours de
passer sous le vent de voir s'il peut
aller chercher un petit vent il va à la
cote et voici peu remonté ses équipiers
doivent lui signaler que brasserie
lorraine est un peu immobilisé pour le
moment ni la lier les repentis et les
authentiques tout doucement elle reste
toujours au vent même si félix mérine
héros parenti
un peu plus vite c'est dur c'est dieu
alors là je peux comprendre quand même
les supporters ouverture musicale tro
les supporters d'harry loi parce que tu
pousses qu'abdel s'est tendue et ce sera
comme ça jusqu'au bout pour l'instant on
ne peut vraiment pas vous dire qui va
gagner
non non on peut à la ola là on peut
vraiment pas dire ça peut être un bon
intéressante pour rebrasse lawrence
arras a plus le jeu sur hambourg ça peut
se jouer sur un banc un mini bon roi bon
mais c'est extrêmement serré sciex
tellement tendu là cette fois ci c'est
là que la course entre deux patrons et
c'est là qu'on voit justement des
équipages qui sont rodés préparés qu'ils
sont prêts et c'est là qu'on voit dans
le mode et pas trop qui peuvent donner
des consignes et prendre la
responsabilité d entre nous car viré
c'est là nous travaillerons à nous qu'à
tenter de capter et si sa manche
ça peut être intéressante pour brasserie
lorraine sera comme ça peut être aussi
intéressant pour les faire chanter love
me grey label champ oui mais venant
vivent de l'autre côté sur les le vent
bascule en bois ya eu un petit moment où
elle a été immobilisé bon mais laguiole
est quand même pauvre elle est quand
même un avantage et quel que soit
quelque chose c'est que félix mérine
sauf à voir une yole qui est beaucoup
plus rapide mais là la course n'est pas
terminée certes on a pris une petite
avance à la dame elle elle s'en moque un
peu du premier va des bras dessus bras
dessous ça dit tout ce que ça veut dire
ça dit qu'en tant que supportrice de la
ior même si on ne gagne pas aujourd'hui
on est à côté mais là la course est un
petit peu relancé parce que félix
périnée toujours plus bas toujours plus
toujours plus bas à essayer de s'en
sortir mais moins rapide et de temps en
temps
iowa ce qu'ils auraient dû rentrer dans
un petit trou de vent et puis elle
repart donc là elle est repartie
on va voir comment ça se passe et les
oies parti et l'hystérie né sous le vent
alors quand on va voir la ligne
d'arrivée je pense qu'elle est à
l'intérieur parce que la façon dont les
bateaux sont mouillés on est au milieu
du chemin le voyait juste sous le vent
et à la bouille
rouge c'est une bouée de chenal qui
n'est pas très large jamais bon pour les
yoles elles sont en manque un petit peu
parce que on peut passer on peut passer
facilement tous les os d'accord alors
direct genre et faire chanter leurs bras
c'est l'oreille sarralbe fait que trois
peut-être pour brasser lorraine et sarah
avec un écart peut-être d'une minute et
demie au président quand on verra on
verra donc tout à l'heure mais reste
encore un petit peu de mère kelly babeau
avec l'ambiance vieux côté de la rive et
kelly voilà long pour rejoindre les
supporters de brasc de lorraine on
obligé de mouiller le maillot
parce qu'ils sont très nombreux une
somme chez eux ici aux marins et il faut
du bruit c'est véritablement le cas de
le dire pour un cahier de loriol on vous
laisse vivre un peu cette ambiance
marinoise des supporters de brasserie
lorraine
[Applaudissements]
c'est le berceau de toutes façons gens
parce que ouais vous voyez il ya des
enfants il ya de tout âge et de toute
façon pour accueillir peut-être en droit
vainqueur ce sera des commandes pour le
bar et pour sept viols de cette
association gol
notes mais d'anglet net 2009 de yola
type 2000 alors justement gens c'est
toujours le même problème quand on va
arriver du côté du marais une affaire
est obligé de virer une pourquoi parce
qu'il ya un catalan avait gardé de pages
et un cataclysme mais en même temps il
montre aussi la presse qui l'aurait
poussé à la faute peut-être que j'admire
et mis la pousse à l'afrique jalili a vu
qu'ils avaient déjà tous ces bateaux
gabarit qui étaient là et le faire et
aller carrément dans les voiliers l'aï
l'objectif perdre du temps basque était
déjà positionné au vent plus honorer
quelques coups d'éclat la patte était
peut-être qu'elle va jouer mais que je
sois ce qui se passe et n'avait pas la
possibilité de descendre la choisit de
rester au vent du chenal vous ne pas
être embêté à bella est là et on copie
basse et lorraine va directement la
victoire voilà donc là on peut quand
même l'annoncé on attend encore un petit
peu parce que tout peut arriver mais
basse il aurait dit sarah va donc
arriver en grand vainqueur dans sa
commune voilà qui va relancer un peu ce
tour de l'arctique parce que regarder
les cas brasserie lorraine va
probablement reprendre une minute et
demi voir johnny luxe plutôt but
peut-être même deux minutes à ufr
chanflor au classement général et va se
retrouver toujours deuxième mais à moins
de dix minutes ça va peut-être retrouver
pratiquement à sept minutes du haka
champions on fera le point tout à
l'heure et enfin le classement est tout
à l'heure mais voilier label voile rouge
de brasserie lorraine sarah énergies
nouvelles qui file qui file qui connaît
qui connaît qui arrivent ces coûts gens
leur contrée cailloux salle comptait
doubler deux yeux fermés les deux cas
mais voilà donc les poussier poehl
exactement fermer leurs yeux est rentré
voilà c'est dégagé c'est carrément vers
n'y a rien qui gêne à part peut-être le
petit variés record mais ça va
tranquille on voit déjà les bouées et
des gens franck la lune
voilà et va couper la ligne vous voyez
les supporters génois soleiha du monde
autre temps l'animal est wayne rooney
nani bomongo kadia et belle bataille oui
c'est vrai entre brasserie lorraine
et effet un champion et attention
attention pour l'arrivée ton code de
brasserie lorraine
ça va et les injures aurel qui va
remporter sa deuxième victoire d'étape
sur ce tour de marie cadieux monde et
qui va et qui va forcément guiraud
prendre du temps sur ufr chanflor est
atteint sur you give me your iv la
victoire donc pour gianni rémy et
georges henry là j'ai regardé regarder
le peuple aux bas rhinois les
inventaires bas rhinois rouge mais c'est
le rouge du supporter c'est pas le rouge
du maillot rouge de leader devant le
rubin kazan jamais lourd probablement
avant la pêche au thon
attention fédé laguiole pour la freiner
là parce que tu arrives et ballan les
supporteurs qui rentre déjà dans l'eau
parce que c'est incroyable c'est
vraiment incroyable
un staff et cet équipage sur cette étape
qui a résisté dans cahier vert
le chanteur les clients c'est le ballon
au bon moment petit à petit thibaut
petit bout par petit bout qui a pris la
tête et qui a poussé un peu parce que
franchement faut le dire hier à
champ-fleuri
alain peut s'enfermer dans les bateaux
dont il a fallu virer sortir de là pour
prendre donc la voie dégagée pour
l'arrivée je le fais par an le col a été
déclenchée pour dire mais à mon avis en
ligne
il ya déjà une minute donc qu'il ya
encore une minute ça va faire du dix30
ça risque de faire du 2 trompe peut-être
dû trois minutes mais mais ça sera
l'egypte pour l'arrivée de super
champion qui sera donc 2e 2e aux marins
le tour jean est relancé il reste quand
même une belle étape il va falloir
retourner demain nous en starlet petit à
petit un si bas s'ils ont un cas
continuez comme ça ce serait parfait et
pourquoi pas attaqué aux flashs en
france sur la dernière étape alors
qu'ils babeau avec janis kelly
alors ça ni 16e victoire d'étape et
victoire à domicile ils vous ne deviez
aujourd'hui bah oui on a bien le rénover
deuxième semaine regard du bavardage
beaucoup de candidats
j'ai toujours pratiquement pas bougé
parce qu'on avait pris 24 à 48 calvi
monassut peu l'addition à son carré de
la tâche s et voilà qu'elle et olivier
nicollin la tonalité
qu'allez vous m'entendez cali un bon
elle a laissé partir diaby rémy ouais
bon c'est vrai qu'il ya de la blanc
s'est longtemps pas spécialement qu'il
aimait brasserie lorraine qui reprend
une 40 à peu près une quarantaine à ufr
chanflor au classement général c'est
déjà une petite opération donc que pond
un bras si l'oreille sa rémunération ne
croyez donc
le protège donc avec nos balises et
regard des gens regarder derrière ce qui
se passe parce que c'est purger pour la
troisième place
non vous rendez compte que il ouvre on
est entrain de régates et bord à bord
avec gfk cette expérience extraordinaire
une belle progression de cette équipe à
louis on a mis tous les bateaux loin et
inscrit pourra mais il va donner un
scribe aura mur j'ai fait car il a dû
virer pour se retrouver sous le vent en
position favorable 7 mai sous le vent et
puis d'ailleurs à eelv on va leur
falloir couvrir parce qu'elle arrive
quand même en pleine vitesse mais
peut-être que puis sauvé des eaux va le
train de repartir devant pour haulotte
pour la troisième place de cette étape
partie ce matin du côté des dans l'est
alors on a l'impression que christophe d
ouais il va vouloir cette troisième
place parce que etc a dit non non non
non non pékin quitté quand même un
nouveau rivet douvres dauphine à l'epo
john locke lancy un vrai challenge et un
gros défi qu'a relevé la parole et de
viols vous voyez bien donc elles devront
ainsi que j ai pas caraïbes il faut
faire attention pour ne pas rentrer non
plus trop dans les bateaux j'ai
l'impression que le vent est mieux
positionné que j ai pas caraïbes qui va
devoir un peu sortir tire un tout petit
bord pour essayer de sortir passer les
bateaux et plus jeune a est toujours
quand même trois mètres carrés à loos a
pas l'air de trois mètres carrés s'est
pas beaucoup mais c'est beaucoup dans
une configuration avec un président
comme ça une petite mer plate
elle a quand même trois mètres carrés un
peu ce si elle négocie bien son prix son
coup
j'ai fait quand il devra agir et se
retrouver sur notre peau alors qu'ali
bongo avec félix mérine à taux plein
tant mieux ça nous fait pas mieux
je m'applique dépendance et nous mêmes
et les pendules à l'heure l'indien l'a
bien beaucoup de bien ça non mais bien
ce moment logement neuf ou dix minutes
annonce eric six mois on me pousse à
niveau
[Musique]
new delhi dow a commencé voici 12 soit
royalement mindanao
ben oui non megan lcd alors rendez vous
est donné demain à félix mais nous
sommes tout se joue là
ah oui oui de vous reparler la drac en
descente la yuuwaa
on va voir beaucoup de choses chose non
c'est une superbe étape mais comment